satoshi nakamoto pops up with his ideas
for bitcoin
and then ross albrecht runs with it
ross albert decides he's going to start
up silk road so initially the people who
were using tor which later is the dark
web people were using tor were just
talking with each other visiting
websites communicating like that someone
figured out hey man we could host
websites
on this thing and they have a lot of
trouble finding the box
so that
is the advent of
silk road all of a sudden ross obrecht
has this idea that he's going to change
the world
by becoming the largest drug dealer on
the planet
so he opens up the silk road and the
only payment instrument he allows
is bitcoin
so if those people out there are
wondering why bitcoin is going at what
44k today
yeah yeah by the time this is out it
could be a hundred thousand or ten
thousand absolutely we'll see who knows
if it's ten thousand i'm going to buy
some
which is a hilarious statement to make
because that statement would be
ridiculously wrong like five years ago
right
people 100 years from now would be
laughing wait it was that low
so he only accepts bitcoin and that's of
course the the initial use case of
crypto is no one wants to admit it today
but the initial use case is we're going
to buy a bunch of pot
we need somebody we need a way to pay
for it
so that's that's what happens uh ross
it's it's really interesting to me if
you uh
if you look at motivations of cyber
criminals
the motivations are status cash
ideology all right
my guys all cash across the board all
cash
ross is ideology
he really believed he was going to
change the world he really didn't i've
been fortunate
i uh i actually know the guy who ran
silk road 2
and have talked to the kid
everything else and uh i will tell you
that those those guys who
are motivated by ideology
they are a completely different breed
they really are it's not you know the
cash guy it's it's
it's low-hanging fruit the the ease of
of
it's hard to stop committing crime
but it's much easier for a
cash-motivated individual to stop than
it is that ideology guy uh that silk
road two guy he's still got it you know
he's not breaking the law but you can
see it's like
he wants to
he he wants to
so it's it's uh
that's fascinating that i i mean the
worst atrocities in human history are
committed
with people that operate under ideology
all the other motivations are much
weaker but you know you think about it
with ross i mean
very bright guy
very bright guy
but think about the amount of cognitive
dissonance that the guy's got
that he thinks he's going to change the
world
by running a drug site
i mean it certainly i mean
could he have changed the world yeah
could he have done it like that
probably not
well i could steal man those arguments i
said listen to quite a few
uh libertarians and you can push that to
anarchists and
you know there's a lot of people that
argue um
so i actually talked to uh to fac a
professor colombia who actually argues
that all drugs should be legalized and
not at a philosophical level political
level but the fact that um all the
negative consequences of drugs that
people talk about
are actually
have to do with other factors in your
life i would agree with that and so
that's a okay but that's more like a
argument about
negative aspects of drugs i think the
ideology comes in where it's like well
nobody should tell you what to do you
should be
you should have the responsibility of
your own actions like uh
um
the government or any other institution
shouldn't be
the uh
the rule setters the constraints for how
you live your life and so that i could i
could see that argument being made and
ultimately if you
uh like
create an open market for drugs how that
could build a better society it might
break down the outdated
the corrupt the bureaucratic
institutions i mean you can make you can
make that argument there's an argument
and let's be fair i want to be fair with
it i mean
could did he change the world
we do have this whole thing called
cryptocurrency yeah in the long arc of
history perhaps yeah we do have that
that's a biggie so
and that might have been for it to take
hold in society maybe the darker parts
of society at first maybe that was
necessary
you